>> ♪ ♪
>> DID YOU HEAR?
DONALD TRUMP WAS NOMINATED FOR
A NOBEL PEACE PRIZE.
WE WENT TO CNN FOR COMMENT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> [SCREAMING].
>> OH, DEAR.
WE WENT TO RACHAEL FOR COMMENT.
>> [BOOING].
>> WE WENT TO THE "WASHINGTON
POST" FOR COMMENT.
>> [CHIRPING].
>> TRUE IN A DECISION SURE TO
ENTICE SMIRKS FROM THE MEDIA,
TRUMP WAS NOMINATED FOR THE
PEACE DEAL BETWEEN ISRAEL AND
THE UNITED ARAB EMIRATES AFTER
BRINGING SERBIA AND KOSOVO TO
THE TABLE.
TRUMP IS THE RIGHT MAN TO
UNMUDDLE THE MIDDLE EAST.
IMAGINE A POOR CNN VIEWER TOLD
HOW TRUMP HATES JEWS AND MUSLIMS
BUT TRUMP AND HIS JEWISH
SON-IN-LAW BRING JEWS AND
MUSLIMS TOGETHER.
AND NORTH KOREA.
REMEMBER BEFORE TRUMP THAT
NATION WAS ON THE VERGE OF
NUKING US.
TRUM UP ENDED THAT PSYCHOLOGY.
NO ONE IN HAWAII THINKS THEY
WILL DIE.
TRUMP WON’T WIN THE PRIZE.
HE IS DESPISED BY THE COOL KIDS
AT THE CAFETERIA TABLE.
HIS DEEDS BROUGHT US LESS WAR
AND MORE PEACE.
THE WHINERS BLAME TRUMP FOR THE
PANDEMIC AND THE VIOLENCE IN
DEMOCRAT LED CITIES.
THAT’S ALL THE LEFT HAS LEFT.
DISTORTING TRUMP’S WORDS BECAUSE
HIS DEEDS SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES.
>> KENNEDY, I WILL TAKE THE MOST
OBNOXIOUS PERSON IN THE WORLD IF
THEY BRING PEACE TO THE WORLD.
ISN’T THAT WHAT TRUMP IS DOING?
>> I THINK HE DOES BEST ON
FOREIGN POLICY.
I AGREE.
THERE IS A LOT ABOUT THE WAY HE
COM
COMPORTS HIMSELF DIGITALLY THAT
LEAVES A LOT TO BE DESIRED.
15 PEOPLE SAID THAT DURING THE
REPUBLICAN NATIONAL CONVENTION.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE PROOF IN
HIS FOREIGN POLICY AND GIVE HIM
CREDIT AND DON’T TRY TO DIMINISH
THAT DEAL BETWEEN THE UAE AND
ISRAEL.
UAE IS LOOKING AT A FUTURE
BEYOND FOSSILE FUELS.
IF THAT’S WHAT IT TAKES TO
NORMALIZE RELATIONS WITH ISRAEL,
I WILL TAKE THAT BRAND OF PEACE
ANY DAY.
IF YOU TAKE HIM OUT AND LOOK AT
ACCOMPLISHMENTS, HE DESERVES
PRIZE.
>> DANA, FROM A SCALE OF 1 TO
3003 WHERE WOULD YOU PUT THIS
AWARD?
>> HE IS MORE ENTITLED TO IT
THAN THE AWARD GIVEN TO
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
THE UAE DEAL IS REAL.
THIS DOLE IS IMPORTANT.
BUT I THINK WHAT IT PORTENDS FOR
THE FUTURE IS MORE IMPORTANT.
OTHER COUNTRIES IN THE MIDDLE
EAST WILL HOPEFULLY FOLLOW THE
UAE’S LEAD.
>> JUAN, 39 YEARS.
THE ONLY PRESIDENT IN 39 YEARS
NOT TO INITIATE A MILITARY
CONFLICT.
YOU HAVE TO LIKE THAT, RIGHT?
>> YOU KNOW, I THINK THIS DEAL
COULD BE GOOD NEWS.
ALTHOUGH I NOTICED THAT THE
OTHER ARAB COUNTRIES THE
PALESTINIANS HAVE NOT EMBRACED
IT.
>> NOT A COUNTRY.
>> HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE GET
NOMINATED FOR A NOBEL PEACE
PRIZE EVERY YEAR.
IN FACT THE SAME RIGHT WING
POLITICIAN WHO NOMINATED TRUMP
FOR THIS ONE ALSO NOMINATED FOR
2018 FOR WORKING WITH NORTH
KOREA AND KIM JONG-UN IS STILL
FIRING MISSILES OFF TO CREATE
TROUBLE.
I DON’T GET IT.
IN THE WOODARD BOOK, HE IS STILL
DOING IT --
>> NO.
>> IN THE WOODARD BOOK, YOU HAVE
THE PRESIDENT SAYING WHEN HE MET
KIM JONG-UN HE KNEW IT WAS GOING
TO WORK.
IT’S LIKE YOU MEET A SPECIAL
WOMAN.
IN A SECOND YOU KNOW IT WILL
HAPPEN.
THIS IS TOO MUCH.
>> IT’S CALLED WORDS BUT FOCUS
ON THE DEEDS.
JESSE?
>> I REVIEWED ALL OF THE WINNERS
SINCE 1904.
THERE ARE SOME OBVIOUS CHOICES.
FDR AND GEORGE MARSHALL AND MLK
AND SOME SNUBS.
YOU HAVE PEOPLE YOU SCRATCH OUR
HEAD LIKE BARACK OBAMA AND THEN
PEOPLE YOU NEVER HEARD.
THEY WROTE A BOOK OR SOMETHING.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE PRESIDENCY SO
FAR SUBJECTIVELY, LOWER THE
TEMPERATURE ON THE KOREAN
PENINSULA AND DO A PEACE DEAL
WITH
WITH ARABS AND KOSOVO THAT
QUALIFIES YOU FOR THIS BECAUSE
THE CRITERIA DONE THE BEST WORK
FOR THE FRATERNITY OF NATION.
AND FOR HOLDING THE PROMOTION OF
PEACE CONGRESSES.
I AGREE WITH KENNEDY.
I WOULD SEND HIS MOUTH TO THE
HAGUE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I WOULD GIVE THE RESULTS THE
PEACE PRIZE.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> SOMEBODY GOT TO BED EARLY.
YOU DID QUITE A LOT OF RESEARCH.
>> JOHNNY DID IT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> POOR JOHNNY.